américa latina' en alerta por la nueva
ola de la pandemia de kobe 19 argentina
rompió un nuevo récord de casos diarios
con casi 30.000 positivos el vertiginoso
aumento de los contagios pese a las
críticas restricciones impuestas en el
área metropolitana de buenos aires ha
puesto al límite a las unidades de
cuidados intensivos de la capital
lamentablemente creo que vamos a empezar
a ver lo que hemos visto en ecuador'
en brasil en perú gente
en los pasillos con oxígeno no
recibiendo
tal vez el mejor tratamiento
espero que no pero espero equivocarme en
brásil los cementerios están desbordados
con más de 368 mil decesos desde el
inicio de la pandemia los hospitales
brasileños carecen de medicinas y las
sucias están copadas en su mayoría por
pacientes jóvenes además la variante
brasileña del patógeno sigue haciendo
estragos por lo que las autoridades
sanitarias pidieron a las mujeres que
pospongan el embarazo
rowling la experiencia clínica de los
especialistas muestra que esta nueva
variante actúa de forma más agresiva en
las mujeres embarazadas son más grados
el viernes colombia confirmó la
circulación de la variante británica en
el turístico departamento del eje
cafetero las autoridades colombianas
impusieron un estricto confinamiento a
cerca de 12 millones de personas en las
regiones más golpeadas por la enfermedad
alertadas por la alta ocupación de las
uci sin embargo muchos comerciantes se
oponen al entierro y reclaman ayudas al
estado la enfermedad muy terrible eso no
lo negamos yo la viví el año pasado
estuve 15 días en cama a causa el
coronavirus pero le digo que es más
fuerte que esa enfermedad la crisis
económica porque con hambre
no se vive ecuador y paraguay también se
encuentran en una situación crítica con
los hospitales saturados y el
agotamiento de los profesionales de la
salud